they don't just want to Snuff out any
any journalism that may go against the
establishment in this case it's the
leftwing establishment but they also
want to Snuff out any activism from from
conservatives as well and so I think
it's really a two-pronged issue the
journalism one is obviously the one that
gets the focus and the one that it has
more more of the press at this point but
it's definitely at an activist level as
well I think the real reason why the
Democrat Party hates me so much is they
they couldn't imagine if they were 100
of me a thousand of me a million of me
they wouldn't exist they'd be done they
wouldn't be able to have any of these
Shams going on because when the
Democrats show up to the capital what do
they do they bring a thousand people
wearing the pink vagina hats they bring
a thousand people for a pro Palestinian
protest they bring a thousand people to
to chant against Amy Cony Barrett or or
Brett kavanau I was one man I was one
man that stood up against the Trump
impeachment sham